mais vous vous rendez compte dans quelle
situation nous trouvons aujourd'hui
c'est parce que les salaires sont trop
bas c'est parce que les retraites sont
trop basses pourquoi parce qu'on n'a pas
fait la réforme des retraites et vous le
savez les retraites notamment les
retraites complémentaires ne sont pas
indexés aujourd'hui sur l'inflation
parce qu'on n'a pas eu le courage de
faire ce que tous les pays autour de
nous on fait la retraite à 65 ans alors
sauf évidemment pour les français qui
sont abîmés par le travail c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que je dis 65 ans
certains de mes camarades 10,64 et avec
65 ans qui est l'âge soleil même des
limites
alors c'est pas mes camarades ça c'est
edouard philippe edouard philippe piat
pas réussi à faire soixante deux heures
et demie et qu'il va nous donner des
leçons pour nous dire faut faire 67 ans
aujourd'hui voilà franchement il devrait
balayer devant sa porte donc 65 ans
pourquoi parce que en allant à 65 ans
qui est la norme aujourd'hui dans les
pays qui nous entourent on a les marges
de manoeuvre financière pour permettre
de revaloriser les petites retraites et
de tenir compte de la pénibilité
notamment moi je veux plus une seule
retraite inférieure au smic net à la fin
de la réforme juste une chez sur les
salaires et sur les salaires je veux
l'augmentation de 10% louise allaire v
sont allés jusqu'à 3000 euros net j'ai
eu à dire tous les français qu'on gagne
sa vie en travaillant qu'avec l'échec
des manuels macron comment est-ce que
nous sommes arrivés nous la france un
très très grand pays agricole à dénigrer
nos agriculteurs et vous le savez le
résultat du quinquennat emmanuel macron
c'est une balance commerciale agricole
déficitaires alors ça parle peut-être
pas au tennis mais la turn et ça veut
dire qu'on importe des produits
alimentaires nous la france oui et en
plus plus qu'on en vend alors que et ses
produits agricoles et ses produits
agricoles et c'est là le vrai problème
ne respecte pas pour 15% d'entre eux les
normes qu'on impose à nos agriculteurs
lorsque je sais ce que c'est une
promesse qu'on peut tenir aujourd'hui à
des agriculteurs des agricultrices qui
nous écoutent est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous pouvez leur dire ils sont
dans un état les agriculteurs des bs oui
mais les électeurs sont des
entrepreneurs ce ne sont pas des
salariés donc parler d'eux les salariés
au smic je pense pas à associer avec
leur 2e je vous expliquais d'argent ils
gagnent certains 600 ou 700 josé que je
le dis le sdrif ferrol par rapport à
lewis mais en relisant vous voulez
assimilés à des salariés ce qui est pas
possible moi ce que je veux faire c'est
créer de la valeur sur les exploitations
c'est permettre que les agriculteurs
effectivement qui sont des entrepreneurs
et plus de chiffre d'affaires sur
l'exploitation comment on fait ça eh
bien d'abord on parle avec la grande
distribution et on s'assure que les
marges de la grande distribution ne vont
pas se faire au détriment nos
agriculteurs ont fait une taxe carbone
aux frontières pour éviter que les
produits arrivent moins cher mais des
taxes et alors qu'ils respectent pas nos
langues et ont bu bess les normes parce
qu'une bonne partie des énormes et
environnement qu'elle vous dire on
baisse les normes qui s'appliquent à
nous avions peur lorsqu'elle songerait
que j'apprécie je précise lorsqu'elles
sont au dessus de la moyenne européenne
parce qu'on n'a pas fait l'europe pour
s'en rajouter une couche et c'est ces
normes qui coûte cher aux alors
heureusement traînards leurs revenus
elle suit par ailleurs ils peuvent faire
aussi beaucoup d'autres choses notamment
de la diversification